des histoires orales, en accumulant ces conversations.
Et la question est : de qui voudriez-vous vous rappeler
si vous aviez seulement 45 minutes avec votre grand-mère ?
Ce qui est intéressant, dans les conversations avec le fondateur Dave Isay,
c'est que nous avons toujours parlé de cela
comme étant un peu un projet subversif,
parce que quand vous y pensez,
en fait il ne s'agit pas vraiment des histoires qui sont racontées,
mais de l'écoute,
et des questions que vous serez amener à poser,
des questions que vous n'auriez pas eu la permission de poser
n'importe quel autre jour.
Je vais vous faire écouter quelques petits extraits du projet.
[Jésus Melendez parlant des derniers instants du poète Pedro Pietri]
Jésus Melendez : Nous avions décollé, et pendant que nous montions,
avant de nous stabiliser,
notre point d'altitude était à 45 000 pieds,
donc avant que de nous stabiliser,
Pedro a commencé à nous quitter,
et ce qui est beau
c'est que je crois qu'il y a quelque chose après la vie.
Vous pouviez le voir en Pedro.
[Danny Perasa à son épouse Annie Perasa mariés depuis 26 ans]
Danny Perasa : Tu vois,
je me sens toujours coupable quand je te dis « Je t'aime »,
et je le dis si souvent. Je dis cela pour te rappeler
qu'aussi moche que je suis, ça vient de moi,
c'est comme écouter une belle chanson à partir d'un poste de radio déglingué,
et c'est agréable de garder la radio près de la maison.
(Rires)
[Michael Wolmetz avec sa petite amie Debora Brakarz]
Michael Wolmetz : Voilà, c'est la bague que mon père a donné à ma mère,
et nous pouvons en rester là.
Il a économisé et l'a acheté,
et il a fait sa demande à ma mère avec cette bague,
et alors j'ai pensé que je devrais te la donner
pour qu'il puisse être avec nous pour cela aussi.
Donc, je vais te passer le micro maintenant, Debora.
Où est le bon doigt ?
Debora Brakarz : (Sanglots)
MW : Debora, veux-tu m'épouser ?
DB : Oui. Bien sûr. Je t'aime.
(Baiser)
MW : Les enfants, voici comment votre mère et moi nous nous sommes mariés,
dans une cabine à Grand Central Station avec la bague de mon père.
Mon grand-père a été chauffeur de taxi pendant 40 ans.
Et il venait chaque jour ici prendre des gens.
Donc, ça parait l'endroit approprié.
Jake Barton : Je dois dire que je n'ai pas vraiment choisi
les échantillons précédents pour vous faire pleurer
car tous vont vous faire pleurer.
L'ensemble du projet est fondé sur cet acte d'amour
qui est l'écoute elle-même.
Et ce principe de construction d'une institution
sur un moment de conversation et d'écoute
représente une grande partie de ce que fait mon entreprise,
Local Projects, en général, dans ses projets.
Nous sommes une boîte de design multimédia, et nous travaillons
avec un large éventail d'institutions différentes sur la construction
d'installations multimédias pour les musées et les espaces publics.
Notre dernier projet concerne le Cleveland Museum of Art,
ou nous avons créé un projet intitulé Gallery One.
C'est un projet intéressant
parce qu'il a commencé avec cette énorme extension de 350 millions de dollars
du Cleveland Museum of Art,
et nous avons été amenés spécifiquement dans cette pièce
à développer de nouvelles capacités, de nouveaux publics,
au moment ou le musée lui-même était en expansion.
Glenn Lowry, directeur du MoMA, s'est exprimé on ne peut mieux quand il a dit :
« Nous voulons que les visiteurs cessent d'être des visiteurs.
Les visiteurs sont transitoires. Nous voulons des gens qui vivent ici,
des gens qui soient propriétaires. »
Et donc ce que nous faisons c'est déployer un large éventail
de différentes façons pour que les gens interagissent réellement
avec les pièces à l’intérieur de ces galeries,
de sorte que vous pouvez toujours avoir accès à la galerie traditionnelle,
mais si vous êtes intéressés, vous pouvez réellement vous engager
avec une œuvre d'art individuelle et connaitre le contexte original
d'où elle vient, ou de manipuler l’œuvre elle-même.
Ainsi, par exemple, vous pouvez cliquer sur cette tête de lion,
et voilà d'où elle provenait, 1300 ans av. J-C.
Ou cette pièce-ci,
vous pouvez voir la chambre réelle. Cela change vraiment la façon dont
vous regarder ce type de peinture à la détrempe.
C'est l'un de mes favoris parce que vous voyez le studio lui-même.
Il s'agit d' un buste de Rodin. Vous percevez le sentiment
de cette incroyable usine de créativité.
Et il vous fait penser littéralement à des centaines
ou des milliers d'années de la créativité humaine et comment
chaque œuvre individuelle se trouve dans une partie de cette histoire.
Voici Picasso,
bien sûr incarnant tellement le 20ème siècle .
Et donc notre prochaine interface, que je vais vous montrer,
exploite effectivement cette idée de cette lignée de créativité.
C'est un algorithme qui permet en fait de parcourir
la collection du musée proprement dit en utilisant la reconnaissance faciale.
Donc, cette personne fait des grimaces différentes avec son visage ,
et c'est en fait pour choisir les différents objets
de la collection qui sont semblables à ce à quoi elle ressemble.
Et donc vous pouvez imaginer que, comme les gens sont en train d'interagir
à l'intérieur du musée lui-même, vous obtenez ce sentiment
de lien affectif,
cette façon dont notre visage se connecte avec des milliers
et des dizaines de milliers d'années.
Il s'agit d'une interface qui vous permet de dessiner
et piocher ensuite des objets en utilisant ces mêmes formes.
Donc, de plus en plus, nous essayons de trouver des moyens
pour que les personnes conçoivent des choses à l'intérieur même des musées,
d'être créatif même si ils cherchent
la créativité des autre et tente de la comprendre.
Donc, dans ce mur, le mur des collections,
vous pouvez voir toutes les 3000 œuvres d'art toutes en même temps,
et vous pouvez réellement être l'auteur de vos propres
visites guidées du musée, de sorte que vous puissiez les partager,
et que quelqu'un puisse faire un tour avec le directeur du musée
ou un tour avec leur petit cousin.
Mais pendant toute la durée ou nous avons travaillé
sur cet engagement pour Cleveland,
Nous avons également travaillé en arrière-plan
sur ce qui est réellement notre plus grand engagement à ce jour,
qui est le mémorial et le musée du 11-Septembre.
Nous avons donc commencé en 2006
en travaillant au sein d'une équipe avec Thinc Conception
pour créer le plan directeur original du musée,
ensuite nous avons fait tout le design des médias
à la fois pour le musée et le mémorial ainsi que la production médiatique.
Ainsi, le mémorial a été ouvert en 2011,
et le musée va ouvrir l'année prochaine en 2014.
Et vous pouvez le voir sur ces images ,
le site est si crue et presque archéologique.
Et bien sûr, l'événement lui-même est si récent,
quelque part entre l'histoire et l'actualité,
c'était un énorme défi d'imaginer
comment faire vivre un espace comme celui-ci,
un événement comme celui-ci, pour réellement raconter cette histoire.
Et donc ce avec quoi nous avons commencé
c'était amener une nouvelle façon de penser à la construction d'une institution,
à travers un projet intitulé Make History,
que nous avons lancé en 2009.
Donc, il est estimé qu'un tiers du monde
a regardé le 11-Septembre en direct,
et qu'un autre tiers du monde
en a entendu parler dans les 24 heures ,
ce qui permet de voir naturellement quand est arrivé,
ce moment sans précédent de porté mondiale.
Et donc nous avons lancé cela pour recevoir des histoires
provenant du monde entier,
grâce à la vidéo, à travers des photos,
à travers l'histoire écrite,
et donc la façon dont les gens ont vécu ce jour,
qui était, en fait, ce risque énorme pour l'institution
d'effectuer le premier déplacement de cette plate-forme ouverte.
Mais cela a été couplé en même temps avec ce stand des histoires orales,
vraiment le plus simple que nous ayons jamais fait ,
où vous vous situer sur une carte.
est en six langues, et vous pouvez raconter votre propre histoire
sur ce qui vous est arrivé ce jour-là.
Et quand nous avons commencé à voir les images incroyables
et les histoires qui en sortaient
de partout dans le monde -
c'est évidemment une partie du train d'atterrissage -
nous avons vraiment commencé à comprendre
qu'il y avait cette symétrie étonnante
entre l'événement lui-même,
et la façon dont les gens racontaient les histoires de l'événement,
et comment nous, nous devions raconter cette histoire.
Cette image en particulier a vraiment capturé
notre attention à l'époque,
parce qu'elle résume tellement cet événement.
Il s'agit d'une prise du tunnel Brooklyn-Battery.
Il y a un pompier qui est en fait coincé, dans la circulation,
et les pompiers se trouvent à deux kilomètres et demi du site
et se dirigent vers lui
avec 30 kilos de matériel sur leur dos.
Et nous avons reçu cette incroyable courriel qui disait :
« Lorsque j'étais en en train de regarder les milliers de photos sur le site,
J'ai découvert de manière inattendue une photo de mon fils.
Ce fut un choc émotionnel, mais une bénédiction de trouver cette photo »,
et il nous écrivait pour dire :
« Je tiens à remercier personnellement le photographe
d'avoir exposé cette photo,
car elle en dit plus que les mots ne peuvent décrire pour moi
d'avoir accès à ce qui est probablement
la dernière photo prise à jamais de mon fils. »
Et cela nous a fait vraiment prendre conscience
de ce que cette institution devait être
afin de réellement raconter cette histoire.
Nous ne pouvions nous contenter d'une narration historienne ou curative
objective à la troisième personne sur un événement comme celui-ci,
quand vous avez les témoins de l'histoire
qui vont faire leur chemin
à travers le musée lui-même.
Et nous avons donc commencé à imaginer le musée,
avec l'équipe de création au musée et les conservateurs,
penser à la façon dont la première voix que vous entendriez
à l'intérieur du musée provienderait en fait d'autres visiteurs.
Et nous avons donc créé cette idée d'une galerie d'ouverture
appelée We Remember.
Et je vais vous montrer un extrait d'une des maquettes,
qui vous donnera une idée de ce que c'est que d'entrer effectivement
à ce moment du temps
et d'être transporté dans l'histoire.
(Vidéo) Voix 1: j'étais à Honolulu, Hawaii. Voix 2: J'étais au Caire, en Egypte.
Voix 3: Sur les Champs- Élysées, à Paris. Voix 4 : Au collège, à U.C. Berkeley.
Voix 5 : J'étais à Times Square. Voix 6 : São Paolo, au Brésil.
(Voix multiples)
Voix 7 : Il était probablement environ 11 heures du soir.
Voix 8: Je roulais vers le travail à 5h45, heure locale, dans la matinée.
9 voix : Nous étions en fait en réunion
quand quelqu'un fit irruption et dit :
« Oh mon Dieu, un avion vient de s'écraser sur le World Trade Center. »
Voix 10 : J'essayais de façon frénétique d'obtenir une radio.
Voix 11 : Quand j'ai entendu cela à la radio -
Voix 12 : J'écoutais la radio.
(Voix multiples)
Voix 13 : J'ai reçu un appel de mon père. Voix 14 : Le téléphone a sonné, il m'a réveillé.
Mon collègue de travail m'a dit d'allumer la télévision.
Voix 15 : Alors je suis passé à la télévision.
Voix 16 : Tous les canaux en Italie montraient la même chose.
Voix 17: Les tours jumelles. Voix 18 : Les tours jumelles.
JB: Et vous vous déplacez à partir de là
dans cet espace ouvert, caverneux.
Il s'agit du dit mur de boue.
C'est l'authentique, mur creusé à la base du World Trade Center
qui a résisté à la réelle pression de la rivière Hudson
durant une année complète après l'événement lui-même.
Et donc nous avons pensé à ramener ce sentiment d' authenticité,
de présence à ce moment-là
dans l'exposition elle-même.
Et nous avons raconté les histoires vu de l'intérieur des tours
à travers ce même collage audio ,
donc nous avons entendu des personnes parler littéralement
de la façon dont les avions sont venus percuter le bâtiment,
ou de la façon dont ils ont pris les cages d'escalier.
Et lorsque vous faites votre chemin dans l'exposition
où il parle de la reprise,
En fait, nous nous projetons directement sur ces moments
d'acier tordu de toutes les expériences des personnes
qui ont littéralement creusé sur le dessus de la pile elle-même.
Et donc vous pouvez entendre des histoires orales -
des gens qui travaillaient effectivement sur ce qu'on appelle les bucket brigades
comme vous voyez littéralement les milliers d'expériences
à partir de ce moment-là.
Et lorsque vous quittez ce moment du récit
du 11-Septembre,
nous tournons alors le musée de nouveau dans un moment d'écoute
et parlons effectivement aux visiteurs individuels
et leur demandons leurs propres expériences sur le 11-Septembre.
Et nous leur posons des questions auxquelles
on ne peux pas vraiment répondre, le type de questions
que le 11-Septembre suscite en nous tous.
Et ce sont donc des questions comme :
« Comment une démocratie peut faire l'équilibre entre la démocratie et la sécurité ? »
« Comment le 11-Septembre a-t-il pu arriver »
« Et comment le monde a changé après le 11-Septembre ? »
Et donc ces témoignages orales,
que nous avons cumulés déjà depuis des années,
sont ensuite mélangés avec des interviews
que nous faisons avec des gens comme Donald Rumsfeld,
Bill Clinton, Rudy Giuliani,
et vous mélangez ensemble ces différents acteurs
et ces différentes expériences,
ces différents points de vu sur le 11-Septembre.
Et soudain, l'institution, encore une fois,
se transforme en une expérience d'écoute.
Alors je vais vous faire écouter juste un court extrait
d'une maquette que nous avons fait sur une partie de ces voix,
mais vous allez vraiment sentir
la poésie de la réflexion de chacun sur l'événement.
(Vidéo) Voix 1: 11-Septembre n'était pas seulement un événement propre à New York.
Voix 2: C'est quelque chose que nous partagions, et c'est quelque chose qui nous unissait.
Voix 3: Et j'ai su quand j'ai vu,
les gens qui étaient là ce jour-là se precipiter
pour porter secours aux gens qui leurs étaient été connus ou inconnus.
que c'était quelque chose qui pouvait nous tirer d'affaire.
Voix 4 : Toute l'effusion d'affection et d'émotion
qui venaient de notre pays a été quelque chose de réel
et restera toujours en moi.
Voix 5: Encore aujourd'hui, je prie et je pense à ceux
qui ont perdu leurs vies,
et ceux qui ont donnés leurs vies pour aider les autres,
Mais je me suis aussi souvenu de la fibre de ce pays,
de l'amour, de la compassion, de la force ,
et j'ai vu une nation se réunir
au milieu d'une terrible tragédie.
JB : Et donc lorsque les gens continuent leur chemin hors du musée,
réfléchissant sur leur propre façon d'avoir vécu et perçu l’événement,
ils passent ensuite dans l'espace réel du monument lui-même,
parce qu'ils ont remonté un grade
et nous avons été impliqué dans le mémorial
après avoir fait le musée pendant quelques années.
Le designer original du mémorial, Michael Arad,
eu cette image dans son esprit de tous les noms apparaissant
de manière indifférente, pratiquement aléatoire,
une réflexion vraiment poétique au dessus de la nature
de l’événement terroriste lui-même,
mais c'était un défi énorme pour les familles, pour la fondation,
certainement pour les premiers intervenants,
et il y a eu une négociation
et une solution a été trouvée
pour ne pas créer d'ordre d’apparition de façon chronologique,
ou alphabétique,
mais à travers ce qu'on appelle la contiguïté significative.
Donc, ce sont des regroupements des noms eux-mêmes
qui apparaissent de manière indifférente, mais qui en fait ont un ordre,
et avec Jer Thorp, nous avons créé un algorithme
pour prendre des quantités massives de données
pour réellement commencer à relier l'ensemble de ces différents noms entre eux.
Donc, c'est une image de l'algorithme proprement dit
avec les noms brouillés pour des raisons d'anonymat,
mais vous pouvez voir que ces blocs de couleur
représentent en fait les quatre vols différents,
les deux tours différentes, les premiers intervenants,
et vous pouvez réellement voir à l'intérieur les différents étages ,
et puis les lignes vertes sont les liens interpersonnels
qui ont été demandées par les familles elles-mêmes.
Et donc quand vous allez au mémorial,
vous pouvez réellement voir l'organisation globale
à l'intérieur des différents bassins eux-mêmes.
Vous pouvez voir la façon dont la géographie de l'événement
est reflété à l'intérieur du monument,
et vous pouvez rechercher un nom individuel,
ou dans ce cas un employeur, Cantor Fitzgerald,
et voir la manière dont tous ces noms,
ces centaines de noms, sont en fait organisés
sur le monument lui-même,
et utiliser cela pour naviguer sur le mémorial.